Good morning John. On Monday I did "Top 5
Conspiracy Theories" and then you did "Top
6 Conjoined Twins" and now I'm going back
to Top 5 because I just can't best you. With
the "Top 5 Stories That Should Have Been Conspiracy
Theories But Aren't Because They're Actually
Real Conspiracies".
So my friends, let's start this thing in the
beginning with Operation Snow White. So you
know the Church of Scientology, I did not
put them in the conspiracy theories video.
If Scientologists believe that we're all the
reincarnated meat-bodies of alien spirits
of the race that came to the Earth 75 million
years ago and were destroyed by their leader
Zenu, then I'm fine with that. But we should
take from that that these are people who are
OK thinking outside of the box. So during
the 1970s the scientologists didn't like how
the US government was getting all up in their
face about how freaking weird they are. So
they decided, to prove that they weren't weird,
to destroy all government records that portrayed
Scientology in a negative light. They did
this amazingly effectively. They infiltrated
136 government agencies, they wire-tapped
people, they hacked computers. Operation Snow
White included no less than 5000 people, making
it the largest infiltration of the US government
in history.
Number 2, MK Ultra. In the 1960s, it is true
that the CIA was conducting illegal government
mind-control experiments on people. The unwilling
test subjects of MK Ultra were given LSD,
they were verbally abused, physically isolated,
put in sensory deprivation chambers, and the
conspiracy theorists' dream; in 1973 the CIA
director ordered all MK Ultra files destroyed.
Number 3, the Tuskegee experiment. From 1932
to 1972, the government of America intentionally
gave ineffective treatments to 400 black men
with syphilis. It was all part of what was
supposed to be a six month long study. Turned
into a 40 year long study, in which almost
half of the men died of Syphilis or related
complications.
Number 4, "Remember, Remember the 5th of November".
I kind of feel like I have to explain that
Guy Fawkes wasn't a big deal in this thing.
There were a lot of people working on the
plot to blow up the British Parliament in
1605, and its like we call it "Guy Fawkes
Day" but he was the guy guarding the gunpowder.
Obviously not an important dude.
Number 5, the business plot. This is an excellent
example of why kids shouldn't go and get a
face tattoo or something because 10 years
down the line, something that seems like a
really good idea right now, might very well
seem like the worst idea ever. So in 1933
a group of wealthy American capitalists, including
George W. Bush's grandfather tried to overthrow
Franklin Delano Roosevelt and install a fascist
dictatorship. Say what! At the time apparently,
it didn't seem like a bad idea. All the right
wingers were like "This guy Roosevelt is commy-ing
up this place. All these government created
jobs being given to people of all socio-economic
statuses, races and religions. Helping the
poor! Commi, commi, commi, commi". At that
time, in the 30's, fascist dictatorships were
kinda all the rage. It was working well in
Italy, it was working well in Germany. So
fascism seemed like a quick fix to these guys
- "lets get ourselves a nice charismatic
general to run the country and we'll do all
the behind-the-scenes work". So they chose
General Smedley Butler to lead their little
military coo, but General Butler was like
"What the frick you guys. You didn't even
look this up? Roosevelt and I are totally
like buds. I love that guy, why would I lead
a coo against my man Franky. D?". So Smedley
spilt the whole plot to congress he was like
"These guys tried to freaking overthrow the
government and they wanted me to be in charge
afterwards. This is messed up". And somehow,
the conspiracy continues because none of the
people who tried to overthrow the American
government were ever brought upon charges.
And there you have it, my "Top 5 Actual Conspiracies".
John, I will see you on Monday.
End screen time. Thank you once again to my
friend Jocelyn for helping us out with this
episode and for not falling down the rabbit
hole of conspiracy theories. Additionally,
on my play channel, youtube.com/hankgames,
I've decided that I'm going to start playing
"Lego Harry Potter" as soon as I hit 15,000
subscribers. So if you want to see me playing
a Harry Potter game, then go to youtube.com/hankgames
and subscribe.